this is the old trl studios i know from
back in the day so we pulled up one of
your first appearances oh my god don't
roll take please shantae i want to see
that just watching my mom and how hard
she worked was more of an inspiration to
me as a latina woman that's jennifer
lopez watching her first in studio
appearance on mtv's trl circa 1999. i
didn't expect all this this is
crazy cbs morning's host gayle king
surprised the singer as she and her
marry me co-star maluma stopped by the
studio jennifer this is the old trl
studios i know from back in the day it's
so funny coming in the door downstairs i
was like i remember this yes you were a
frequent guest here so we pulled up one
of your first appearances oh my god
don't roll take please shantae i want to
see that just watching my mom and how
hard she worked was more of an
inspiration to me as a latina woman um
the hard work the perseverance you know
through hard times and stuff like that
watching her was probably the best thing
i could have ever had the best thing you
could ever have j lo's reaction
priceless and malumas
you love that i love that
jayla yup remember her
[Music]
a very big deal like the actress says
she had already given her breakout
performance in selena the 1997 biopic
about the late tejano superstar who was
killed when she was 23 and e.t was with
a then 27 year old jennifer on the set
of the movie selena was such a great
role model and she broke so many
barriers and did so much great stuff for
the latino community and just
gave all these little girls somebody to
look up to that the movie in that sense
also you know could help in that way
just breaking down barriers in hollywood
even you know we've had so many problems
you know getting good roles and doing
stuff and i mean look at this i mean as
an actress you know one of the great
things about doing things is not just to
do fictional characters but to also
recreate this incredible human life you
know and um for me that's why it's such
a it's such a blessing it's an honor to
be able to
to do this and when et spoke to jen 20
years after its release she shared how
the role impacted her life i honestly
believe it was
god sent me that role for a reason
so i could learn from her no you're not
promised tomorrow and you have to
you have to love and live for today and
you know it just taught me so many
things on so many levels the film helped
the new york natives skyrocket to
superstardom and become the global
sensation we know and love today her
latest project a rom-com called marry me
they say if you want something different
you have to do something different
why not
yes
[Music]
i'll marry you
you
and e.t was at the premiere tuesday
night where she and her beau ben affleck
showed off some pda
hey
give her kids
this is just a good date night it's a
great date night we're super happy
um
what can i tell you we're just
having a good time i would be remiss if
i didn't say you were standing taking
photos in front of a sign that says
marry me
it's very big i didn't realize how big
[Music]